un stylo un cerveau d'ipex du papier à
karonga un texte continue mon trajet
j'arrive vers la gare de lyon quand je
vois un gars qui se dit vraiment très
fort comme un lion il me dit claude m6
est ce que tu veux qu'on se moque ses
hématomes était plus qu clé saint-amand
ta box
il m'a fait bus de la ville quand je dis
les [ __ ] salies solar cela me lasse
mais laisse les salir solar sur ce salut
ça prouve que leurs apps pas juste
parler comme ça sur une musique et c'est
peut-être une recherche assez spécifique
et rythmiquement même quand j'écris je
pense qu'il faut que ce soit que ce soit
dit j'ai vu la concubine de
l'hémoglobine ça c'est très symétriques
et puis arrive les balles balancées des
rafales de balles au vocal et c'est
plein de trucs saccadé balancer des
rafales de balles vocale c'est comme si
on enlevait un ak 47 ou m sixtine qui
partaient à la ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
langue toucher la terre ferme
que peut faire que des constats noir est
amer quand je fais un constat noir
j'aime qui est une morale à la fin
j'appelle la tête tant que le plus tôt
que la réaction épidermique donc le mot
devient une arme louis mot devient
devient une arme c'est le seul moyen
avec lesquels le chétif peu de s'en
tirer
je suis pas chétif en août et là ça peut
aller de boby lapointe pour certains aux
exercices de style qui vont dans le sens
du durable serge gainsbourg en passant
par aux jeux pal est offert et c'est
c'est toujours bien d'avoir j'ai pas de
la culture française dans notre style de
rap fait totalement différé de l'excès
qui peut y avoir parfois dans le rap
américain
[Musique]